so thank you everyone for joining us
today my name is Eric tweet I'm a data
Wrangler on the foreign contamination
screen team at ncbi and today I will be
sharing new tools and development by the
FCS team to remove contaminants from
genome assemblies which will improve the
genome assembly submission process at
ncbi
and there are other FCS team members
here today we have Terence Murphy the
product owner of the ncbi ref seek
offering and Deacon Sweeney the FCS
technical lead who will help to answer
questions during the webinar
so an overview for the webinar content
today first I will go over a brief
background on genome assembly
contamination and the current pipelines
in USA and CBI to detect contamination
next I will provide details on the new
and CBI FCS implementation that includes
publicly available screening tools and
finally I will run through a live demo
to show how a typical user could run FCS
tools in the cloud
we Define contamination as sequences
present in a data set that do not
originate biologically from the
indicated organism
contamination can occur at many steps in
the genome assembly process starting
from the initial DNA extraction all the
way to data submission
and there are multiple potential sources
of contamination in a genome sequencing
project
in the example of an insect genome there
could be contamination from its host
plant and bacterial contamination from
endosymbionts or introduced during lab
sample preparation
in the context of genome assemblies
foreign DNA can be assembled as complete
or chimeric contigues and ideally a
contamination screening pipeline should
be able to identify contaminants from
multiple sources and distinguish those
from Context belonging to a user-defined
source organism
contamination detection is important
because contaminant sequences have
negative consequences when introduced
into the ncbi archives
contamination pollutes the public
archives and reduces the statistical
power of Big Data analyzes
and there are multiple published reports
of contaminated entries in ncbi
databases
in addition scientific conclusions can
be inaccurate when sequences are
incorrectly attributed to organisms
this paper is a notable example that
showed bacterial sequences that were
initially thought to be the result of
horizontal Gene transfer into a
tardigrade were most likely to be
bacterial contaminants associated with
the sample
and the use of secondary data analysis
to identify evolutionary conservation
can also be affected
as this paper points out proteins
conserve by diverse bacteria are in
reality shared human contamination
ncbi has maintained a legacy FCS
pipeline for 20 years and is used to
screen hundreds of thousands of
prokaryote genomes and thousands of
eukaryotic genomes each year
's a diagram of the steps commonly used
in genome assembly including an ncbi
contamination screening step prior to
final assembly submission
one Pitfall with the current approach is
that contamination identified at the
time of submission to ncbi can delay the
release of the data and depending on the
extent of the contamination a user might
have to go back and redo some of the
prior assembly steps such as assembly
correction or annotation
public access to FCS tools allows genome
submission submitters to screen
assemblies much earlier in the process
for example immediately following the
contig assembly stage this allows users
to identify and address contamination
issues earlier and save the headache of
redoing work
and in the future we will have a system
set up to allow genome submitters to
submit their clean sequences along with
contamination reports to streamline the
submission process
now I want to give a broad overview of
the two tools that are currently part of
the FCS Suite
FCS adapter is a re-implementation of
ncbi's Vex screen Pipeline and looks for
adapters commonly used in sequencing
Library preparations
the general workflow involves a fast
stay format validation step
a blast search step using High
stringency parameters to look for exact
or near exact matches
a filtering step to remove weaker hits
and a processing step to handle
overlapping hits and edge cases
the pipeline produces a cleaned fasta
file that has sequences either trimmed
or removed depending on the extent of
the adapter matches
the second tool we call fcsgx which is a
brand new tool that looks for
contamination from foreign organisms
the workflow here is to split the fast a
and mask low complexity regions followed
by an alignment step that operates in
two passes
the alignment step uses a large database
of diverse genomic sequences from
eukaryotes prokaryotes and viruses
and higher scoring alignments from the
first pass are retained for a second
pass of the alignment shown here in the
diagram
next alignments are refined and coverage
and score information is collected
and the pipeline produces a final report
that lists sequences with various
contaminant cleaning actions
users are guided to remove sequences
entirely trim off ends or internal
segments and some lower confidence
alignments may be in scope for further
review
in the future we will Implement a clean
fasta step similar to FCS adapter that
automatically generates a final fasta
file after interpreting the action
report calls
the major goals for the FCS tool suite
are that we want the tools to be easy
for users to run we want them to be fast
we want FCS to be reliable so
reproducible across different types of
compute environments we want the tools
to be cloud ready and we've been able to
test FCS in both Amazon web services and
the Google help platform
we want contamination results to have
high sensitivity and specificity
the current FCS pipelines that ncbi Miss
many contaminants so we want a more
sensitive tool
and at the same time it's important that
we do not remove valid sequences from
assemblies so we want to minimize false
positives
we also want to use the same code that
ncbi uses for screen screening incoming
submissions to make that process
consistent
and we've released components of FCS and
have received user feedback on our
releases
we've also released new software
releases that have addressed some user
requests
and here's the HTML link to the FCS
GitHub page which we will visit as part
of the live demo
as far as system requirements you need a
Unix operating system and python version
3.7 and above
if you have root access to your system
you can use the FCS Docker image those
without root access can use singularity
and I've listed recommended and
requirements in terms of CPU cores and
memory for running FCS adapter and GX
for GX specifically the 500 gigabyte
memory requirement is for holding the
large reference database and accessory
files
and execution can utilize up to 48 CPU
cores
if these requirements are prohibitive
locally both Amazon and Google cloud
services provide hosts sufficient for
execution and can be run at the cost of
only a few dollars per genome
so now we're going to transition over to
the live demo
I'm going to demonstrate examples of
both FCS adapter and fcsgx
for SCS adapter we're going to be
looking at contaminants in setsy fly
I'll show you how you would copy a file
from your local computer to a virtual
machine and we're going to run FCS
adapter using the singularity image
for fcsgx we're going to be looking at
contaminants and AP complex and parasite
plasmodium and run using the docker
image
all right
so just to provide you with some
orientation here
on the screen up top I have the set of
commands that I will run to get the FCS
tools up and running some of these I've
already done prior to the webinar and
others I'm just going to copy and paste
into the terminal to save time
the FCS GitHub has Wiki pages that
provide a step-by-step process to run
the tools
and on the bottom here is the
interactive terminal window that I'll be
using to execute the commands
I also want to mention that this demo
assumes that you have a cloud instance
set up so here I'm already logged into
my Google Cloud platform virtual machine
instance
again we've tested on both gcp and
Amazon web services and some users may
be able to run the FCS tools on their
local compute Farms as well
so for FCS adapter we're going to be
looking at data from itsetsy fly and
here's the ncbi genome assembly page for
this particular organism just showing
for reference purposes
the first step would be to download this
assembly into my working directory and
copy it into the cloud virtual machine
instance
so these are the commands right here
I've excuse me so I've already done
I've already done that
um so this Crow command retrieves the
genome and this gcloud compute SCP
command copies it from my local machine
to my virtual machine instance and
Amazon web services has a similar
command to the gcloud compute SCP so
again I've already done this I'm going
to go to my SCS adapter
um
directory and show that I've kind of
downloaded this already so then you
would log into your virtual machine
instance and then you would download the
runner and the singularity image so
again I've already done those things
with curl commands uh making the runner
user executable with this chmod command
I'm sorry I'll just move on to the next
step which would be to run the program
itself
I should mention too for those of you
not familiar with Docker and Singularity
the images are essentially a file system
and parameters used to execute code with
all of the software dependencies baked
in the benefit here is that with each
new release of the software you don't
have to worry about compatibility issues
so it's all self-contained in that sense
so to run and uh to run FCS adapter with
Singularity you need your fasta input
file shown here
I've specified an output directory
uh you use a uke or Pro parameter
depending on your Source genome so since
we're working with that setsy fly I have
specified Uke we're working with the
singularity container engine and I'm
specifying the FCS adapter
singularityimage file.sif that we
downloaded with a curl command in the
previous step
now it takes a couple minutes to run
this whole genome through FCS adapter
and uh so just for simplicity's sake
we're going to run a single sequence
which will be a little bit faster
and so uh the the program is running now
I do want to point out that there are a
there's a warning message and a fixed
the problem message here
this is currently expected output and so
users running this program shouldn't be
concerned that something is running
incorrectly when they see these warning
messages
again just as a reminder of an overview
of the pipeline we're first validating
the fasta file doing a stringent blast
search filtering alignments and then
making a set of final calls based on the
parsed alignments so this log that's
printing in the screen right now
provides a reported the pipeline going
through the various steps
and a successful run should print a
bunch of completed success messages at
the bottom of the screen
so now that we've completed
um
the Run we can actually look in the
output folder
so here are the output folder contents
and many of these files are logs or
records of parameters used the important
output here is this FCS
adapterreport.txt
and so we're actually going to look at
the results here for the full data set
first not just for the one particular
sequence that we ran on FCS adapter
so you can see that this is a tab
delimited file format with the sequence
accessions in the First Column the
length of the sequence is next followed
by an action so these are either going
to be action underscore trim or action
underscore exclude depending on whether
it's suggested that a adapter gets
trimmed off the end or in the middle or
if the sequence should be removed
entirely
this range provides the base pair range
of the match the adapter
and then the final column has more
detailed information about the adapter
matches so as I kind of scroll through
this file you can see that the primary
matches are to Illumina Paradigm PCR
primers and Rubicon genomics DNA
seek dual index sequences
now we're going to look at the specific
sequence
that we ran just the individual sequence
that we ran on FCS adapter
uh so from the from the overview that I
gave from the full file we can see that
this sequence is about 2 KB and there's
a suggested trim at the beginning of the
sequence in the first 58 base pairs and
it's matching this alumina PCR primer
so what I want to do now is go to my
internet browser just for comparison
purposes
uh you might might not know that ncbi
has this webvex screen tool where you
can enter your sequences and search for
vector or adapter contamination so I've
already gone ahead and pasted this
sequence into this box and we're
actually going to just run that screen
right now on this sequence
and so you can see the webvex screen
results produces uh matches that align
with what we saw with FCS adapter
there's a strong match from 6 to 58 and
then the suspect origin from the first
to fifth base pair
and you can see the alignment
um to this Illumina PCR primer in the
pairwise alignment viewer down below so
what this is saying is that there is a
strong match at the 6 to 58 base per
interval and given that it's close to
the end of this sequence it's suspicious
errors could occur during due to
sequencing errors but it's recommending
that that entire end of the sequence be
trimmed off
and this is what we commonly observe
when we see adapter contamination and
genome assemblies is that adapters are
commonly found at the ends of context
now the ncbi web uh page for this
particular assembly doesn't have any
details about this particular assembly
method but the ENA equivalent for this
setsy fly does detail that the whole
genome shotgun assembly is based on a
combination of sanger454 and alumina
reads and so it makes sense why we could
observe a Lumina sequencing primers in
that data I just wanted to kind of show
that
so now I think before we transition over
to fcsgx I should mention that kind of
the primary benefit that we see for FCS
adapter is that instead of looking
through individual sequences like this
on web-based fetch screen we can Screen
through entire genome assemblies in a
very high throughput manner
so now we'll transition over to fcsgx
and look at contamination from foreign
organisms
The genome assembly of interest for this
demo is going to be an AP complex and
parasite plasmodium
so go back to my terminal window and go
to my FCS GX directory
okay so the steps to get this running
largely follow the steps for FCS adapter
we're going to start by downloading the
runner and the genome data which I've
already done
the next step is to create a shared
memory space
there are various methods of doing this
which may depend whether or not you have
pseudo permissions on your compute
environment and these are described in
the wiki and these have to do with what
I mentioned earlier on the PowerPoint in
terms of the shared memory requirements
used to store the database files
optionally you can also provide a
path for a local backup copy of the
fcsgx database
so when you run fcsgx for the first time
it will actually download the database
from the FTP site
which in our tests currently takes about
an hour in North America
and then the actual pipeline of
GX only takes on the order of minutes a
minute or two
once you have the GX database saved as a
local backup the actual process for
substitute for your screening subsequent
genome assembly should be quite quick
so to run fcsgx we'll run this Command
right here I've already downloaded the
local backup copy so we don't have to
wait an hour for that to happen
uh but the requirements for running this
pipeline are your input fasta file I
specified an output directory
I've specified the path to my shared
memory location
and also the location for the save
database files on disk
we also
specified the split fasta parameter to
split scaffolds into contigs and specify
this tax ID parameter which is in ncbi
taxonomic identifier number that
corresponds to your declared Source
organism so this is this is particular
specific to the plasmodium species that
we are testing and will help GX
differentiate between Source organism
sequences and contaminant sequences
so I'm going to run this right now you
can see there are messages relating to
the
um the database I'll just kind of scroll
up here so you can see these it's
recognizing that the database files are
already stored on disk so it's going to
go right to the screening pipeline
now at this point we are doing the
masking step
and you can see above are some of the
parameters used in the Run
again just an overview of this
particular pipeline after the masking
step is a two pass alignment step
followed by some post-processing of the
alignment the alignments and coverage
values to produce a final set of
contaminant calls
so upon the completion of a successful
run you should see these contamination
summary reports at the bottom of the
screen and I'm going to kind of make the
screen a little bit larger so you can
see
so the contamination summary report that
prints out at the end of The Run kind of
details uh the contaminant taxonomic
divisions in terms of the sequence
counts matching different taxonomic
divisions and the base counts
corresponding to those divisions so from
the printout here we have seen that we
see that the primary contaminants are G
proteobacteria and rodent comprising
over a megabase almost two megabases of
of contaminant sequence
and then there's also an action summary
report below that contamination report
that gives a list of the total uh a
summary of the actions that a user could
take to rid The genome assembly of
contamination so in this example almost
all the sequences are recommended for an
exclude action which means they should
be removed entirely from The genome
and one sequence is marked with a trim
action meaning it was identified that
the sequence contained likely contains
some plasmodium sequence but also
contains some contaminant sequence
now if we look in the output folder you
can see two files that are generated
using an fcsgx run
one is the GX report file which provides
the final contaminant cleaning actions
and the second is a tax taxonomy report
file which is a more intermediate output
that users can look at for additional
details about the contaminant calls
so we'll look at both of these
we'll look at both of these first we'll
look at the GX report
so similar to the FCS adapter output
this is a tab delimited file that
provides summary information about
sequence successions in the first column
the
coordinates corresponding to the
contaminant ranges in the second and
third columns respectively and then the
action is kind of in the middle there so
similar to the action report that we
just saw the action summary report
almost all these sequences are
recommended for exclusion
and I'll kind of scroll down and you can
see that the predominant matches here
are rodent corresponding to Mouse and
this G proteobacterium methylis
methylococcus capsulatus
all right
now you can use
um some parsing commands to look at uh
more specific uh sequences of Interest
so maybe I'm interested in that one trim
call that that GX suggested so I can do
a grep command to find that sequence you
could also use grep 2 find sequences
corresponding to certain
taxonomic groups for for example
so I have the sequence accession for
this trim call and now what I want to do
is look at the intermediate file the
taxonomy report
for this particular sequence
the way that this taxonomy report file
is organized is it has some summary
information in the first few columns
about the sequence size any repeat
any repeats identified and the length of
regions matching any of the top four
hits
and then what these pipe symbols
separate is up to four distinct uh
matches for any given sequence so the
taxonomy report file will report up to
four distinct matches to per individual
sequences
um and for each taxonomic division so
for example protist alveolic it will
report a maximum of two matches
the advantage here is that if closely
related organisms share common
contaminants GX reporting multiple
divisions can potentially distinguish
between valid contaminants and artifacts
due to Shared contamination
the double tilde symbols in the sequence
identifiers indicate that this
particular sequence is assigned as
chimeric by GX
so if you look at the results for this
first 2700 bases
you can see that there are two strong
matches to alveoliths
shown here
and here
and the assignment of this particular
subsequence is protist alveolute with a
coverage of 100 percent
then in the next 600 bases
there is one strong match to Mouse
and again it covers that entire span of
615 base pairs and it's a signed
contaminant rodent with a coverage of a
hundred
now this is the high coverage
information is strong evidence that it
is a valid trim but even more uh what
increases our confidence about this call
is that we know that there are other
Mouse contaminants elsewhere in the
assembly there were a lot of exclude
calls that were wrote in and so that
increases our confidence that trim calls
are valid as well
now I'm going to go back to the genome
assembly page for this organism and
point out that this assembly has an
Associated publication that indicates
that this plasmodium parasite is a
malaria parasite of rodent so finding
rodent sequences in this assembly is
unsurprising
and I also ran a blast search of this
particular sequence
and you can see that the graphical
results correspond to what we observed
in fcsgx
so the first 2700 bases correspond to
different plasmodium sequences and on
the right here
the region that fcsx called as a trim
correspond to Mouse
so we're highly confident that this is a
this is a valid trim
so that's it for the demo portion the
last thing that I want to just give a
brief overview of is the FCS GitHub page
this is just navigated to the home page
right now which gives kind of a broad
overview of FCS and some more details
about the individual tools FCS adapter
and fcsgx
I mentioned the wiki Pages I'll just
click on the fcsgx Wiki page
and so this page gives us kind of a
summary information about fcsgx it's
prerequisites and then I'll kind of
scroll down here this gives a full kind
of quick start so how you would download
the runner script how you would get test
data that we've tested with just to make
sure that the pipeline is working as
intended
and then it gives pipeline examples for
both doc Docker and singularity
and on the bottom it gives different
usage examples ways to interpret the
output and on the bottom some known
issues
we also have some technical information
about uh the algorithms underlying the
pipeline
so please check out the GitHub page if
you're if you're interested in more
information about that
in our Wiki we also have information
about FCS adapter the more intermediate
FCS GX taxonomy report file
as I mentioned we have set up
documentation for both AWS and gcp so if
you're excited about using this in the
cloud but don't know how to get started
uh this would be a really good resource
to use
and finally we have some release notes
that kind of describe any major updates
that we have to the software so as you
can see we've already had a few new
releases since the initial release in
March and we've responded to some user
feature requests with this method
so please again check out our GitHub
page if you're more interested about
these tools
um if you're testing these out and have
issues or suggestions please reach out
to us on the FCS GitHub issues page
you can also contact us with questions
and suggestions about FCS through this
email refseq support nlm.nah.gov
and major updates to fcfs are oftentimes
posted through the ncbi social media
channels which are shown here
we have a lot of people to thank for
work on this project
um and the last thing I would like to
mention is that FCS is part of the NIH
comparative genomics resource an nlm
project to establish an ecosystem to
facilitate reliable comparative genomics
analyzes for all eukaryotic organisms
and I'm happy to take any questions
thanks very much Eric
um so we have some questions uh one of
them is this one which is instead of
removing the contaminants from
assemblies isn't it easier to remove the
contaminants from the Reeds and I
suppose part of the answer this is that
we're talking about things that are
already assembled that we're going to be
submitted
um do people climb even after they
remove stuff from the read that they're
still in the assembly
so this is a good question and for the
adapter specifically I know that there
are
tools out there that specifically
operate and are intended to be used on
reads to trim out adapter sequences so
yeah like you mentioned one major
benefit for this implementation
would be that uh
if a user have had already gone through
the step of doing an assembly
um and didn't do like an adapter removal
step then this would be beneficial
um and then as far as the
uh organisms there's just not as many
tools out there that specifically
operate on reads and so this is
um again uh
something that we think is new territory
in a lot of respects and it also
operates very quickly
um and so it has kind of that high
through component that we're excited
about I also mentioned that we're
wanting to make this publicly available
to make it yeah consistent with the
process that ncbi is currently using to
screen incoming submissions for for
contamination
right so they're so we're using it
mainly on assemblies and so that's why
we have it that way
um okay so here's some other ones um can
you explain like you mentioned two
different containers
Docker and Singularity what are the
differences or damages of using one
versus the other
right so I think Deacon would probably
be the best person to answer this
question and provide additional details
but what I can say for starters is that
uh Docker usually requires you to have
like elevated privileges on your compute
system so if you're trying to run
something locally if you don't have
pseudo permissions on your compute
environment you usually can't run Docker
and so Singularity provides the
advantage there but I think Deacon
should probably jump on and and clarify
any additional points of comparison oh
not at all Erica I think that really
summarizes it
okay thank you
um
so another question
um and this one is relevant for uh
prokaryotic assemblies so the the phage
components where they're in prophase in
the bacterial genomes how how does the
contamination screen handle that or is
it just for eukaryotes oh that's that's
an excellent question
um and it is something that we will
encounter with eukaryotes too uh in
terms of lateral Gene transfers
um so we're currently working on
developing a way to sort of handle these
cases usually we won't report
prokaryote viruses as contaminants and
prokaryote genomes and same with
eukaryotic viruses found in eukaryotic
genomes however we would report say a
prokaryotic virus in a eukaryote genome
but um the same is true with like a
lateral Gene transfer I mean we know
that there are known cases of this and
so uh we're kind of working on you know
do we want to handle these on a
case-by-case basis is there a way to
sort of treat these all similarly and so
this is a Content piece that we're
currently working on but it's certainly
from a biological perspective very
interesting
cool thank you um
so in terms of you know I certainly in
you know myself is a question for me
basically
um so when I run blast searches a lot of
times I can identify easily contaminants
that are present in genetic sequences
is there is there an effort of sort of
going back and looking at things before
we had this tool but like going back
into the archive and trying to find it
more contamination
um in terms of what we did previously or
well it's already in gender
yeah so
um one thing that I will point out is
yeah I mean to do to test our software
and to do kind of validation we
oftentimes do those secondary analyzes
including kind of blast searches and one
thing also that's important to note is
that
you know whenever you're using a
reference-based tool uh you run the risk
of a contaminated database entry kind of
you know creating noise in your results
and so when we were working on
developing this tool one of the things
that we did early on was screen the
genomes that formed part of the database
through the tool itself and you know
mask or I guess ignored self-self
alignments and so in that way we could
identify you know maybe database entries
that could potentially uh create
confounding results
um so we we have done a lot of that
um
both manually and kind of in a
semi-automated method to
to improve uh the the quality of the
results
so that kind of leads into another
question that we have which is
the background database for GX so it
must be already cleaned up it's not it's
different than the glass database for
example
yeah so we have
um
we have made a lot of effort to do clean
clean up both like I mentioned through
manual validation and kind of automated
pipelines to sort of identify what are
going to be very high confidence
contaminants that should be removed from
the database I can't claim that it's
perfect it would be really difficult to
to make that claim
um and we're we're finding
if we find new issues we we plan to
release new database versions with the
but the goal here is that we want the
database releases to be pretty far apart
and so we want to do a lot of the heavy
lifting in terms of the contamination
removal up front
and minimize the increments or or the
you know time frames between successive
database releases but of course as new
data gets released that might improve
our ability to identify contaminants
like if they're clean genomes so we also
want to
consider including additional genomes
that get submitted to be in scope for
the database in the future right exactly
to keep the technology scope
up to date yeah because that's also an
area of our own personal interest is
you know identifying contaminants from
maybe those kind of poorly represented
taxonomic groups
right
um you mentioned in terms of thinking
there's a couple things that uh the GX
database that sounds like that would be
really cool for a blast database it'd be
nice if we had it available for that but
that's a that's another topic
um also you mentioned downloading it
from the FTP side is it not available on
on the cloud providers
we're currently working on that that's
like one of our next
um
next steps yeah yeah because we've we've
received some feedback in in terms of
the download times and are listening to
that and so one of the next steps in the
more immediate future is going to be
making that available on Cloud on cloud
services and thinking about the cloud
services one other question is the do
your does your get up site have a
documentation on you know like
suggestions for setting it up on like
what kind of instant types you should
use instance types you should use on AWS
and gcp yes we uh on the GitHub page we
provide
um specific recommendations for GX as
that is the one that tends to be more
um
intensive in terms of the requirements
so if users are wanting to run both
tools if you follow the setup
recommendations for GX that should be
more than sufficient to run both tools
gotcha okay and I'll just give you one
last question this is another one that's
from me you know we sort of cannot
figure out why the road uh sequences are
in that plasmodium you know where did
the methylococcus sequence come from
because it's a it's a it's a methanogen
so it's like you know
a weird thermophilic bacterium I looked
to see what it was
yeah I I I I guess I'm interested in
that as well and I haven't
I haven't given I guess that's some more
critical thoughts so maybe something
interesting to look at but I mean does
it ever happen that just sometimes is
there any kind of contamination that
arises from some kind of electronic
mix-up when they're trying to assemble
data or something like that
yeah possibly I don't know but it's an
interesting that that organism they you
know sequences that were in there
because it seems to sort of out there
but that's interesting
I think that's it
um so
thanks everybody for coming and um the
materials for this
demonstration and the slides are up on
the FTP side that link is in the
beginning of the slides
yep thank you again everybody for
attending
um and please reach out with questions
and suggestions